ja und beim thema tempolimit habe ich
mich heute aufgeregt nämlich das
erstaunlich ist ich habe mich auf
spricht über die aktuelle diskussion
über das tempo denkt dagegen und damit
bin ich schlauer weise in der minderheit
denn erstmals seit den frühen 90er
jahren ist eine mehrheit der deutschen
für ein tempolimit oder wie es jetzt ein
sicherheits tempo von
120.000 ist haut und die gründe da denkt
man die sind nahe liegen zwei millionen
tonnen co2 ausstoß können wir jedes jahr
sparen wenn wir uns auch dieses
sicherheits tempo reduzieren und sicher
gibt auch ein paar unfälle weniger wobei
die meisten unfälle passieren nicht auf
autobahnen sondern vielmehr auf
landstraßen 60 prozent aller unfälle und
so bin ich immer noch das einzige von
190 ländern weltweit das kein tempolimit
hat ja das stimmt und doch will ich
weiter fahren so wie ich es würde mich
nicht regulieren nicht steuern lassen
nicht von amerikanischen tech konzern in
den algorithmen und auch nicht von
regierungsvertretern die nachher im
vierten schweren konzell die musik und
mir vorbeiziehen oder in regierungs
fliegern über mich hinweg ton an nein es
ist doch so unsere autos sind auch so
gut weil sie jeden tag den
technologischen fortschritt auf den
straßen erfahren jetzt haben wir auch
die kurve gekriegt bei den d autos und
unsere autobahn ohne tempolimit sind
immer noch die allerbesten teststrecken
und was ist mit dem klimawandel auch der
strom von den e autos kommt ihr nicht
aus der steckdose und wird noch
weitestgehend
erwirtschaftet in
kraftwerken aus gas und aus kohle und
das ist meine umstellung mit einer
umstellung auf umweltfreundliche e mails
mehr fürs klima getan als einem reinen
festhalten eines tempels deswegen heißt
es für mich bei den freie fahrt für
immer weniger
die bürger wähle ich bin ja komplett auf
deiner seite ich bin auch gegen das
tempolimit aber ich habe heute mal ein
paar fakten nämlich selbst erschrocken
haben viele dieser dieser diskussion
sind ja nicht mit fakten aufgeladen
sondern mit ideologie hier sind drei
fakten die mich extrem verwundert haben
und die unsere these aber stärken sonst
würde ich sie natürlich nicht vortag 1
autobahn sind in deutschland sicherer
als in anderen ländern mit tempolimit
autobahn sind die sichersten straßen
tempo limitierung erhöht frustration
tempolimit kann keine staus verhindern
und sogar noch ein fünfter fakt weil ich
die wirklich spannend finde autobahn
werden immer sicherer nochmals
deutlicher sicherheits zuwachs zu seit
2009 10 also das ist halt wirklich der
punkt wir sind damit eigentlich sicherer
als in anderen ländern mit tempolimit
und das finde ich halt wirklich
schwierig es immer diese
sicherheitsthema eingebracht werden den
etwas völlig recht denn ist es ja nicht
so dass wir auf unseren ganzen autobahn
rasen können wie die irren überall was
vielleicht jemand denkt denn an ihnen
deutschland wahr sondern wir haben
weitestgehend den deutschland
intelligente verkehrsleitsysteme das
heißt wird irgendwo ein stau ist werden
wir schon von irgendeiner leitstelle
heruntergebremst nicht und dann kommt
einem dieses bild nicht 100 oder wie
auch immer wir fahren dürfen 80 oder
sonst was und das ist die situation mit
der wir umgehen sollten ich habe mich
das gefühl dass einer von euch für das
tempolimit ist oder
bevor ich eine praktische erfahrung
einbringt die schweiz hat ein tempolimit
das wurde heim 10 oder 30 das wurde
eingeführt in den achtziger jahren wegen
des waldstettens das nicht stattgefunden
hat aber das tempolimit ist geblieben
also die begründung war eine ganz andere
als die die man jetzt eigentlich immer
noch braucht und ja ich kann nur sagen
deutschland ist ein autoland die
freiheit was er traurig genug ist findet
leider allzu oft nur noch auf der straße
statt und nein das daran ist ihr
festhalten und noch einmal das ist
ideologisch damals eingeflogen wurden in
der schweiz mit der begründung des
mannes heute eine spannende frage sagt
wir müssen daran festhalten wir müssen
einmal unsere zuschauer mitnehmen dass
in den koalitionsverhandlungen den
möglichen egal ob ampel oder jamaika
alexander kissler da wird ja genau
darüber diskutiert was glaubst du wird
es jemand schaffen dort jemand sind dann
die grünen und teile der spd dieses
tempolimit durchzudrücken der idee die
fdp würde ich sagen ja ich würde sagen
bei koalitionsverhandlungen markiert man
ja bastionen die man nicht räumen will
also die unverhandelbaren punkte werden
auf den tisch gelegt doch schon gesagt
sie sind bereit ich glaube ja klar ich
weiß aber ich glaube dennoch dass man
einem allgemeinen trend folgt der wird
ja eben korrekt beschrieben die mehrheit
der deutschen haben hätten ihren frieden
gemacht mit der tempobegrenzung ich muss
sagen ich bin grundsätzlich gegen
verboten sofern auch gegen
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung aber ich
finds auch etwas übertrieben das jetzt
wie es bei ihnen gegangen hat jetzt zum
zur bastion der freiheit hochzujazzen
also ich meine wir haben ja so viele
probleme wo ich die freiheit stärker
unter druck sehe wenn ich nur die hohe
steuer und abgabenquote see wo also
jeder einzelne in seinen
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten eingeschränkt
ist durch eine aberwitzige und die
weiterführende steuern abgabenlast da
müsste man wirklich mal den menschen
erst freiheit ermöglichen die
fähigkeiten geben also immer mehr geld
im portemonnaie lassen aber insofern
würde ich sagen ein verbot ist schlecht
aber es wäre jetzt kein kein indikator
für das wird eine komplett und feiere
gesellschaft werden aber wir können doch
nicht sagen hier sind wir schon so
belastet also akzeptieren wir noch eine
belastung auf der anderen seite in denen
die ob es diese entlastung in diesem
bereich
ist ja ist ja interessant eine
interessante sache in der schweiz ist ja
in der schweiz ist es ja nicht ein
tempolimit sondern der schweiz wenn man
da 131 132 kriegt man schon einiges
gewicht
432 leider nicht nein es hat unglaublich
strenges pusten regime und ich muss
einfach noch einmal sagen das ist
ausfluss einer wirklich ich sage das
immer dass ich die hilfe des verkehrs
kolchose das ist die verkehrsplaner das
modell über das nein das heißt einfach
dass das der start ganz massiv also auch
die geringsten tempoüberschreitungen mit
härtesten bussen bestraft andere delikte
werden in den innenstädten zum teil
lässt man sie laufen aber gegen den
autofahrer herrscht zero tolerance &
noch einwurzeln alexander kissler ich
glaube das darf man nicht unterschätzen
die die freiheit der fortbewegung das
grundrecht auf mobilität auch auf eine
gewisse geschwindigkeit das darf nicht
leichtfertig eingeschränkt werden weil
das wie immer mehr passieren auch im
zeichen des klimawandels wo der staat
die kontrolle über den fehlenden
angesprochen über die art wie wir uns
fortbewegen die vor bewegung wird
verteuert durch höhere energiepreise das
heißt wir kommen in so eine art
gesellschaft wie im mittelalter das nur
noch die könige und die ganz reichen
sich dass die mobilität leisten könne
und das fußvolk muss dort in
öffentlichen vergeben die vorstellung
rechten züge bestellen sie politisch
steht die these auf dass es nicht
passieren wird das wenn deutschland am
boden bekommen ich glaube nicht dass die
grünen darauf beharren und vor allem
glaube ich dass die fdp es sich nicht
leisten kann und auch teile der spd zu
sagen wir machen das mit wenig wenn
kleinigkeiten
schlichtungsversuche ist das letzte
spiel war es obwohl ich gegen das
tempolimit bin was ich glaube ich jetzt
anstelle von christian lindner und alena
werbung mal diskutieren würde und zwar
das dynamische tempolimit das wäre
eigentlich hervorragende
schlichtungsversuchen weil das zeigen
wir das ist nicht nur ideologie sein
pragmatismus was bedeutet das dynamische
tempolimit das bedeutet wenn zum
beispiel sonniger tag straße ist
komplett leer gibt es kein tempolimit
regnerischer tag straße ist begehrt wie
geht das fürchten lernen lässt das kalt
also das heute technologisch ja wohl
drin sein dass man das einstellen kann
und es wäre doch ein tolles nationales
digitalisierungsprojekt also da ist er
für mich so das dynamische tempolimit
weniger ideologie mehr pragmatismus ist
würde ich gerne christel in amberg
verschnaufen tisch legen und sagen wenn
es technisch möglich ist macht das oder
ist man tageweise auch entscheiden kann
wie die wetterlage ist und die lange
alten alten vw golf den vielleicht
spd-wähler dennoch hat weil sie nicht ob
das so einfach möglich ist oder diese es
gibt doch die besten entwickeln auch
staus hast du meinst nicht dass es
übertragen wird ins auto daher
verstehe ich sag ja spannende so schön
ist digitalisierungsprojekt für
deutschland wäre das aber das finde ich
wirklich toll wenn es drei stück ist
sonnenschein warum braucht man ein
tempolimit straße / event aber verregnet
ist düster ist zweispurig ist dann macht
man an den tagen tempolimit und das
fände ich wär ein toller
schlichtungsversuch bei mir geht es in
der politik viel zu sehr im schwarzweiß
hardliner position eins hardliner
position zwei das dynamische tempolimit
wer aber finde ich hingegen mal etwas
was die mitte wäre und das werde ich ein
tolles projekt von
auf der ampel oder jamaika
[Musik]